nothing
[Music]
What's up, calm down
I feel fine Now I'm in the campaign
come on Goodbye
[Music]
three times
with an appointment to sacrifice her And then
why this This breed of cats are
delicate, the truth is, not having a nose like that
and not having a snout But hey  I
bring her to San Antón like the
previous cat brought and she is already 11 years old,
that is, she is being taken care of, she is being taken
care of very well.
give back the
grace that by keeping them a little
at least So as not to spend so much on
veterinarians if necessary
[Music] her
name is Rita and the truth is that we are
more or less neighbors of the neighborhood and
every year whenever I have had  perro
Well, we like to come to San Antón. I don't think
it helps much, but it is a
very Madrid and very centennial tradition
that we like to maintain